it's pretty incredible how good eggs are
for you one of the most nutritious foods
on the planet eggs offer multiple
benefits to anyone who eats them while
eggs were not always thought of in such
a healthy way doctors and nutritionists
have cracked poached and scrambled those
old-school ways of thinking
eggs are a well-known source of protein
it can help with weight loss increase
muscle mass and lower blood pressure
they contain all the essential amino
acids the human body needs eating eggs
can also lower your risk of heart
disease stroke and other health problems
why eggs are high in HDL cholesterol
that's the good kind your body needs a
single egg contains more than half the
recommended daily cholesterol intake
eggs contain choline a nutrient that's
used to build cell membranes and produce
signaling molecules in the brain just
one egg can contain more than 100
milligrams of choline a significant
fraction of the National Academy of
Sciences recommended intake of 550
milligrams for men and 425 milligrams
for women if you're eating an omega-3 or
pasture-raised egg that egg is helping
to reduce triglycerides in the blood
which in turn lowers the risk for heart
disease eggs can even help your eyes
stay healthy they contain various
antioxidants two of which can reduce the
risk of cataracts and macular
degeneration eggs are also high in
vitamin A vitamin A deficiency is the
most common cause of blindness in the
world so if you want to eat a little
healthier you might want to consider
adding a few more eggs to your diet
you